[Musique]
tout près du parlement mais loin des
regards
la simple citoyenne catherine mais kenna
prend le temps de souffler la vie n'est
plus la même pour cet ancien ministre
libéral qui a fait ses adieux à la
politique
ces années tumultueuses comme ministre
de l'environnement semble déjà loin
derrière même si elles ont laissé des
traces j'ai très vite compris
et il ya des gens qui voulaient utiliser
que j'étais capable contre moi femme
ministre elle est devenue la cible des
opposants au prix sur le carbone exposés
ou harcèlement et aux attaques
constantes
même du personnel politique de son
propre parti lui reprocher de laisser
trop de place à ses émotions j'ai eu
un message
qui m'a dit chalmé bout calme et
wasquehal b une autre preuve selon elle
ce traitement inégal réservé aux femmes
en politique si on a trop émotionnel on
est maman
n'est pas assez forte alors on peut pas
regagner
[Musique]
alors que catherine mais ken ash cherche
à défendre la cause climatique autrement
hors de la politique d'autres ministres
quittent leurs fonctions mais pas par
choix les attractions come back
le nom de dave show disparaîtra bientôt
de son bureau de circonscription de
kingston en ontario la ministre sortant
des aînés a perdu son élection par mille
voix elle partage l'amertume de la
défaite avec deux autres collègues du
cabinet qui ont aussi mordu la poussière
maria moncef et bernadette jarden
la transition est difficile pour les
ministres des fêtes surtout que des
pilotes se bat contre un cancer mais il
ne regrette rien de son passage aux
communes et aux cabinets
elle s'est sentie écoutée par justin
trudeau autour de la table du conseil
des ministres spécialement quand elle
parlait de la précarité des femmes
aînées une attention qui tranche avec
son passage dans le privé quelques
années plus tôt comme cadre au sein de
l'entreprise bombardier
est
souvent la seule femme au table
décisionnelle c'était très difficile
d'être entendu raconte elle
au parlement les femmes sont toujours
sous représentées
il ne compose que le tiers des députés
justin trudeau a déjà promis que son
prochain conseil des ministres sera
encore paritaire un critère encore perçu
par trop de gens comme étant symbolique
déplore catherine mais kana non sommes
pas des trois faits oui il ya des
considérations quand on fait un cabinet
c'est sûr mais nous sommes des femmes
nous sommes 50 % la population c'est
dans cet édifice anonyme du centre-ville
d'ottawa que l'équipe de transition de
justin trudeau essaie de composer le
cabinet idéal représentation régionale
diversité culturelle et parité des
genres quatre femmes de son ancienne
équipe ministérielle ne seront pas de
retour au parlement il faut donc trouver
les bonnes candidates pour les bons
postes la politique comme bien d'autres
secteurs
parmi les nouvelles élues des noms
circulent comme celui de l'ancien leader
syndical pascal saintonge elle fait la
tournée des commerces locaux pour
rencontrer ses électeurs
à peine élue elle demeure prudente
lorsqu'on évoque la possibilité qu'elle
soit nommé ministre
la raison principale pour laquelle je me
suis lancé en politique c'était pour
représenter les gens de grand froid
selon elle la diversité autour de la
table des précédents cabinet a donné des
résultats par exemple le programme pour
les garderies il ya des femmes autour de
la table qui ont poussé ce genre de
dossier laisse à ses yeux d'autres voies
gagne aussi être mieux entendues pour
avoir re portrait plus représentatif de
la société je pense aussi que les
personnes trans entre autres comment
vivent beaucoup c'est que j'ai là il ya
encore la violence à rendre à la
communauté est génétique de cluses
femmes de la communauté gaie et
syndicalistes du milieu culturel il
arrive à ottawa avec un bagage qui est
le sien
le rôle en soit dans la puberté lune
arrive et l'autre équipe est possible de
transmettre l'expérience mais l'ancien
ministre se permet un conseil
c'est surtout les gens vont vous dire
comment vous devez vous aviez regardé
par les îles vont vous conseillez
comment faire les décisions rester
fidèle à ses valeurs malgré la rudesse
de l' aventure politique
[Musique]